part one of the absolute worst roommate  i have ever had in my life and how we  got him to move out senior year of  college i lived with one of my platonic  guy friends there were three reasons why  he was the absolute worst roommate ever  first being that he was absolutely  disgusting not a neat freak i'm actually  on the messy side but when you come home  to this every single day  oh my gosh it changes you when we bring  it up to him he saw nothing wrong with  that second being he was the absolute  most disrespectful person i have ever  met in my life he was funny like he was  a funny guy so he could always get  different girls right problem was he was  also cheap so he never wanted to take  those girls out to dinner i would come  home on like a tuesday from work and  he'd be having this like elegant meal  with a girl from tinder running out of  time like for part two